[Musique]
donc cette semaine aussi 17
le nouveau long métrage d'anne fontaine
donc une réalisatrice qu'on connaît bien
qui a déjà tourné beaucoup de longs
métrages qui s'appelle police alors
police c'est pas du tout ce à quoi on
pourrait s'attendre on suit pas une
enquête particulière on fit surtout je
dirais un cas de conscience en 7 qui se
posent à trois policiers qui travaillent
ensemble dans une unité parisienne donc
on découvre assez finement leur univers
leur solitude leurs problèmes leurs
l'ours histoire personnelle aussi qu'ils
sont mixées dans tout ça et se pose de
cases conscience de libérer en tout cas
de laisser filer with par un réfugié et
qu'ils doivent ramener c'est une mission
qu'on leur a confiées à l'aéroport voilà
donc je vais pas vous en dire plus sage
et sans quasiment que virginie efira
c'est exceptionnel omar sy aussi et
grégory gadebois évidemment aussi qu'on
venait découvrir ce film dans nos salles
cette semaine
[Musique]